hey guys it's max welcome to our iPhone
se vs. pixel three a camera comparison
right now I'm recording video using the
selfie camera both support 1080p 30 and
you guys could see the difference in
sharpness and dynamic range as I'm
turning around and you guys can also
here at the microphone differences as we
jump between these let me know which one
sounds better down below starting off
with this indoor high dynamic range shot
the se is a little bit brighter where
the 3a exposed darker the 3a has a
little bit more noise but a little bit
more detail and it's actually just a
little bit darker overall but the
dynamic range is actually very similar
moving outdoors I like that the se shot
is brighter it looks more true to life
and it's actually a little bit sharper
as well next I took this macro shot and
they look quite similar once again the
3a is exposing darker and if we pop in
here you'll see that the SE does have a
little bit more detail in the trend of
the 3a exposing darker continues with
this shot but in this one I actually
like it better I like that the 3a has a
wider selfie camera but for some reason
actually focused on the background and
it underexposed my face making a look
worse another benefit of the pixel is
that you can use portrait mode on
objects not just people so that is
really great but comparing the leaves
and the flowers the SE gets the white
balance right and it has more detail
moving back to video the se looks a
little more stable these are both 4k 30
but the SE can actually do 4k 6d and
then if we compare the actual quality
the white balance is spot-on on the
iPhone and we're seeing a little bit
more detail as well the pixel does allow
you to zoom in more than the iPhone but
it does look quite bad and then if we
just go ahead and zoom the same from the
full image we could tell that the iPhone
has a little bit more detail back to
photos this was a tough tiny McGrane
shot where everything was quite dark in
real life the se made it look really
nice with its newest smart HDR the 3a
once again underexposed which doesn't
look great and then for a portrait shot
the 3a forces you to crop in but in this
case it does look better with more
detail and more realistic blur
once again for well lit shots the iPhone
nails the exposure and white balance and
it has a little bit more detail where
the pixel just looks a bit too dark if
you're somebody likes to zoom in on
their phone the pixel does way better
Google's algorithm gives us nice detail
with a five times zoom compared to the s
key which just looks a little soft and
here's a mixed light portrait the three
A's colors are way off the SE nails the
colors right and we have good detail as
well the same thing goes for this Shaw
we had daylight from outside and
overhead we had warm light the SE nailed
the white balance where the 3:8
definitely looks off but everything
changes when we go into lower light the
Basel 3a has better colors better detail
and less noise and now even without the
night mode the 3a is exposing brighter
than the iPhone which is weird and
finally we have an ultra low light shot
the pixel 3/8 does have night mode you
guys concede the massive difference
compared to the se which doesn't and
finish it off here is some low-light
video let me know your thoughts down in
the comment section below do you think
that pixel 3a did a better job due to
Google's extra software or do you think
the iPhone se did a better job thanks to
that a 13 Bionic processor I want to
hear you guys's opinions go ahead and
click above to subscribe and if you guys
want to see some extra videos we have
summer right over there on the side
thanks for watching this man max and
I'll see you in the next video
[Music]